[Music]
hello I'm Alex Tina beauty director of
Glamour magazine and I'm here today was
one of my ultimate icons Victoria
Beckham to talk it's true to talk about
her new capsule makeup collection with
Estee Lauder first of all I had no idea
you were such a makeup junkie you love
makeup I love makeup I always have and I
always say I'm a girl's girl and I like
to empower women and make women feel
like the best version of themselves and
I really do and with makeup I have
learned so much over the years of doing
so many photo shoots standing on so many
red carpets but when I had the
opportunity to create a capsule with
Estee Lauder that is a brand that I wear
hmm that I respect I was just so excited
and working with the team was a dream
come true
[Music]
what's really interesting is you've
divided it into four looks for four
cities that you like I'm from London I
live in London I spend a lot of time in
LA that's my second home
I spend time in New York I show my
collection in New York and I spend it a
lot of time in Paris as well and I
wanted to create different looks because
my makeup changes not just dependent on
whether it's day or night but also
depending on where I am so the customer
can get that Paris look with the red lip
and the hint of green on the eye she can
get LA which is youthful and glossy and
then London which is smoky and dark and
cool and has a little bit of a
rock-and-roll feel about it but you got
new formulas well you work with the labs
on specific formulas just for you we did
which is something new for Estee Lauder
as well so I feel that we've we've
really pushed the boundaries but both
brands here and I would wanted to ask
you specifically about this shape this
is very much my brand and it's a color a
tone that has become somewhat signature
to me and my brand it's important that
these are all things that I wear just
for different occasions this is actually
matte as well which i think makes it
feel younger and cooler but it's also
very editorial which is another thing
that I wanted to share with women out
there is I've learnt so much I've worked
with the best makeup artists in the
world see this is what's amazing you
really have put so much of yourself into
this and it really shines through this
is something that all women can be part
of it as well it doesn't matter how old
you are where you're from and everybody
can be part of this even if they just
buy one product I want them to feel
special
you're in a house with a lot of men
probably thinking makeup is there
anything that like you know has Harper
seen anything and been like oh I love
this she has she's the only person that
has actually seen this because she's
very very girly and she loved fashion
she loves makeup and yeah we don't get
our nails done it again yeah this
morning when I was getting ready
actually and I was having my hair done
she was she was standing there in her
school uniform and I could see she was
hinting to the hairdresser what about me
or about me and so she so she did so she
had very smart plans for school today
much better than where I'm normally
doing them so she loves it and that's
something that we do together I love
that and then find the question I want
to ask you I know this is gonna be hard
but if you had to pick one favorite or
two which one that's so difficult I
would probably say the nude pencil and
the nude lipstick and because it's
something that I would wear every single
day and I would say the morning or as oh
my god that's amazing which gives you
that real useful glowy look so it's hard
to pick a favorite and you know but then
if I'm going to stand on the red carpet
I want the eyeshadows I want the glitter
on my eyes as well you know I'm not
afraid to wear makeup but I want it to
be I want it to be cool and I really
think that that's what we have Korean oh
yeah and I love the fact that you love
wearing makeup thank you so much you
very much thank
[Music]
you